It's amazing to see this room filled like
this. It's super exciting. I'm going to emcee
the event, or moderate the event.
So the first thing I was asked to do is actually
tell you about a series of events that are
a part of the McDermott Award. You're now
at the event called Future of the Library.
The next one will be the keynote lecture by
David Adjaye on March 29th. Then, we're going
to be discussing Future of the Campus, March 30th.
And finally, a panel on Future of the
Museum on April 28th. So that's sort of the
big picture of what's going to happen.
But today, it's a great pleasure for me to
moderate conversation on the future of the
library, its architectural possibilities,
cultural, organizational, and technological
pressures as an institution, and various forms
of magic it presents. Magic was a word that
came up many times last night in the conversation
that I got to eavesdrop on. The MIT Library
Task Force, we had some of the panelists tonight.
So I'll try not to sound like there's an inside
joke about this. But magic was, in that event,
related to the material and spatial dimension
of the library, to its architecture, to the
encounter with material instantiation of knowledge
and books and other information objects--
I learned that term. And magic seemed apt
as at least one of the terms by which to describe
the socializing dimension of the library,
being in it together.
So for now, I will introduce the participants
in this event by a fairly standard bio. And
I hope you won't mind that. So that we can
save space, time, for these pretty talkative
enthusiasts of the library, of library architecture,
and I'm relieved to say, of the book.
First-- and it may not entirely follow the
order that we've been given for the presentations.
But I'll introduce David Adjaye, who set up
his first office in 1994, and a few years
later, in 2000, founded Adjaye Associates
and immediately won several prestigious commissions.
In Oslo, he designed a Nobel Peace Center.
In London, his design for the Whitechapel
Idea Stores pioneered a new approach to the
provision of information services. Later projects
in London included the Stephen Lawrence Centre,
with teaching and community spaces, Rivington
Place, an exhibition venue and resource center,
and the Bernie Grant Arts Centre for performing
arts.
The office, Adjaye Associates, now has offices
in London, New York, and Accra, and is working
throughout the world. In the United States,
Adjaye is the designer of a new home for the
Museum of Contemporary Art in Denver, two
public libraries in Washington, the Sugar
Hill low-income housing development in Harlem,
and a redesigned Ethelbert Cooper Gallery
of African and African-American art at Harvard
University's Hutchin's Center.
Adjaye Associates' largest completed project
to date is the Moscow School of Management's
Skolkovo. While the firm's current projects
include the Smithsonian National Museum of
African-American History and Culture on the
National Mall in Washington, the Alara concept
store in Lagos, the Aishti Foundation Arts
and Retail Center in Beirut, a new headquarters
building for the International Finance Corporation
in Dakar, the new home for the Studio Museum
in Harlem, the Center for Art and Culture
at Colgate University, and a condominium development
for Four Seasons in Washington. And we know
he's on at least a couple of really important
projects right now in a competition with a
few people.
Adjaye garnered many honors and awards for
his work, including a prestigious Royal Institute
of British Architects Bronze Medal for Architectural
Students and the Design Miami Designer of
the Year Award in 2011. In June 2007, he was
appointed OBE, Officer of the Most Excellent
Order of the British Empire for Services to
Architecture. Adjaye recently collaborated
with Okwui Enwezor on the design of the 56th
Venice Art Bienniale, which is last year's
Art Bienniale. And his own comprehensive retrospective
exhibition was held at Haus der Kunst in Munich
and then travelled to Art Institute of Chicago,
where it just closed in January.
Jeffrey Schnapp is Professor of Romance Languages
and Literature and Comparative Literature
and on the teaching faculty in the Department
of Architecture at Harvard's GSD. He is a
founder and faculty director of metaLAB at
Harvard and faculty co-director of the Berkman
Center for Internet and Society. A cultural
historian with research interests extending
from Roman antiquity to the present, his most
recent books are The Library Beyond the Book,
co-written with Matthew Battles. There may
be others, but I augmented something here.
The Electric Information Age book, a collaboration
with the designer Adam Michaels, Italiamerica
II, co-edited with Emanuela Scarpellini,
and Digital_Humanities, co-written with a
team of colleagues.
His pioneering work in the domains of digital
humanities and digitally augmented approaches
to cultural programming includes curatorial
collaborations with the Triennale di Milano,
the Cantor Center for the Visual Arts, the
Wolfsonian-FIU, and the Canadian Center for
Architecture. His Trento Tunnels project was
featured in the Italian pavilion of the 2010
Venice Biennale and at the MAXXI in Rome.
Nader Tehrani is the Dean of the Irwin C.
Chanin School of Architecture at The Cooper
Union. He is also a Principal of NADAAA, a
practice dedicated to the advancement of design
innovation, interdisciplinary collaboration,
and an intensive dialogue with the construction
industry. Tehrani has taught at the MIT School
of Architecture-- so welcome back-- where
he served as the Head of the Department from
2010 to 2014. He has also taught at Harvard
Graduate School of Design, Rhode Island School
of Design, the Georgia Institute of Technology,
as the Thomas Ventulett Distinguished Chair
in Architectural Design, and at University
of Toronto, where he held the Frank Gehry
International Visiting Chair.
As the principal and founder of
Office dA-- so the first incarnation of the
office-- Tehrani's work has been recognized
with notable awards, including the Cooper
Hewitt National Design Award, the United States
Artists Fellowship in Architecture and Design,
and the American Academy of Arts and Letters
Award in Architecture. He has also received
the Harleston Parker Award for the Northeastern
University Interfaith Spiritual Center and
a Hobson award for the Georgia Insitute of
Technology Human Research Building. Throughout
his career, Tehrani has received 16 Progressive
Architecture Awards, as well as numerous AIA,
Boston Society of Architects, ID awards. And
in 2013, 2014, and 2015, NADAAA was ranked
number one in design for Architect Magazine's
Top 50 firms in the United States. And though
it wasn't listed in this bio, which was deemed
provided by the speaker, probably, at some
point, to CAST, NADAA received numerous
awards in the last few years for its Melbourne
School of Design, completed in 2014.
Right. Are you with me?
[LAUGHTER]
Ginnie Cooper, recently retired from the District
of Columbia Public Library, where she served
as Chief Librarian for eight years, a period
during which she was directly responsible
for renovating or rebuilding 14 branch libraries.
Among these are both two libraries designed by
David Adjaye, as well as renovation of Mies
designed Central Martin Luther King, Jr. Memorial
Library. Cooper was awarded the 2013 Jefferson
Award for Public Architecture from the American
Institute of Architects. A librarian since
1970, Cooper worked in libraries in 50-- five
states. Five states, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
Five states and in New York City as Executive
Director of the Brooklyn Public School-- Public
Library. Can you see, I'm just reading these--
She's a past president of the Public Library
Association, a division of the American Library
Association, and a recipient of the Charlie
Robinson Award, made by the Public Library
Association to recognize a public library
director who has been a risk-taker, an innovator,
and an agent for change.
Chris Bourg, finally, is Director of the MIT
libraries. She arrived to MIT in February
2015. Prior to MIT, she served in a variety
of leadership positions at Stanford University,
where she managed the public service facets
of physical and digital library services of
the largest division of the Stanford University
Libraries, with six branches and a collection
of more than 4 million volumes. Bourg's career
began with 10 years of service as an officer
in the United States Army, including three
years on the faculty of the United States
Military Academy at West Point, where she
taught sociology and leadership. She has written
and spoken extensively on the topics of libraries,
leadership, diversity, and social justice.
She's a strong advocate for gender equality,
and was involved in creating and leading the
first Women's Voices and Influence group for
Stanford staff.
All right. So, with that, we have a kind of
order. I hope that didn't put you all to sleep.
And it begins with David Adjaye. So I think
the way we're going to run this is that every
one of you comes here and presents the ten-minute
presentations or responses. And then we're
going to sit down and dive into, you know,
magic.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
OK. Thank you. It's nice to be here, to be
part of this incredible award and to be talking
to you about libraries, which are a very important
space to have a debate about, in terms of
our civic and public life. I have 10 minutes.
I have too many slides, so I'm going to try
to keep it in 10 minutes.
Essentially, I wanted to show you the images.
I'm not going to talk extensively about everything,
but to really talk about the investigation,
since 2000 to this time, that we've been doing
into the nature of the library. And to summarize
that, essentially what has become a key driver,
is this notion of place-making. The library
moves from just being a depository of public
knowledge as the Internet dissolves that archive,
and becomes a place of socializing to gain
knowledge and network place, and a place to
re-imagine different parts of the city and
how it contributes to our public and civic
life.
I'm going to show four examples in different
parts of the world, and hopefully that will
stimulate a discussion. First one is in Gwangju.
And probably most unusual, Gwangju has
incredibly high levels of literacy, an extraordinary place
where there's a Bienniale. And we were invited
to create a pavilion in that Bienniale.
I worked with a writer, Taiye Selasi, and
we imagined the idea of a library as a public
piece of infrastructure, the library as a
public staircase that leads from the street
to the river. This is a kind of quick context
image. But essentially, we conceived this
idea that in this incredible culture that
really has an incredible dynamic of literature
and reading, that we would dissolve the notion
of building into just a place that could activate
engagement. It would be, you know, Wi-Fi-enabled
to deal with all the Internet issues. But also, it
would be a place that somehow would be able
to archive and store information, and be a
place to trade and share information. And
then, at the same time, also just be a structure
that would go up and down to the water and
beyond.
So a big experiment. It's been incredibly
successful, and we were surprised. The building
is designed so that it basically floods when
the high floods come, and it's in two parts.
It's sort of at this river edge, and we'll
go through it.
So it's a concrete and timber structure. The
base is sort of the infrastructure of stairs,
which also have bookshelves indented into
it with cast concrete and sealed. And the
upper level is this timber porous sun shade,
which creates this sort of monument. This
is the timber structure. And then this is
the forum.
Second was the idea of a library in a local
community in London. And the idea was-- in
a very diverse part of London, which historically
has always had huge diversity, about 15 different
languages spoken formally in this neighborhood.
We were to make a new kind of a library infrastructure
system that would essentially try to bring
information to this community and serve as
a support network for the diversity of different
groups and age groups that would use this
infrastructure.
We sought to basically seek to make a library
like a textile and a network of systems that
we connect together, sometimes literal and
sometimes metaphorical. And to create a building
which essentially was a podium, sort of an
extrusion of the street, with a series of
services in it. It would combine life-long
learning, it has a creche, it has dance
spaces, spaces for learning about body and
wellness, outdoor spaces, cafes, and all the
various sort of parts of a traditional library
that you know-- media, computer studies, language
labs, et cetera.
So it became, really, a building which has
this central core in which all the activity
happens. It has the kind of double stair,
which takes you up and down. And you have
a series of plates that are basically set
up to deliver these services and to dissolve
the notion of the library into a perimeter
system of services that are in this main space,
but then a series of window moments, which
allow the user to basically turn away from
the building and, as it were, engage with
their environment. So there is no reading
room. The reading positions are all on the
perimeter system. And then the sort of stacks
and systems, or teaching spaces, are inside
the forum.
It was also the first time that we built a
what would be a kind of Platinum-LEED building
for a library, where there were no ducts.
It works with pressurized floors and a mass
concrete moment structure, which was,
at that time, a big change. So to be highly
environmentally conscious and to also kind
of re-think the services and infrastructure
of this type.
It had this overhanging structure that overhung
the street. It had escalators that bring you
directly off the street. Multi-porous system,
no single entry. And the escalator would bring
you up to the quieter spaces. The ground floor
was more children's library, media, et cetera.
The canopy was basically devised to trap heat
gain-- those of you who know about architectural
heat gain-- and to kind of create an exhaustive
climate moderator for the facade, which will
also work as a new kind of porch to position
the building in the public realm. We were
allowed by the city to make this building
jut out into away from the building line.
Because of this statement about a new public porch.
A new piece of infrastructure, a new, modern
way of creating a public porch, which would
then bring you up into this building and deliver
the various services to you. It very much
welds with the street, which is a market street.
And it's a seven-day market, so it's always
there.
And then the south-facing chamber becomes
this moment where, with this sort of colored
glass, you get these effects. This is that
chamber, the kind of moderator that people
go up and down. And it releases heat at the
top, and allows the building to stay cool in its interior. This is a kind of image of the
interior with the exposed slabs and the way
in which the spaces unfold. Dance spaces.
So the spaces with the vignettes.
We dissolved the notion of the book stacks
and turned them into what we called a landscape,
which allowed people to kind of surf in different
ways. Connections between floors. And then
the rooftop, a cafe with retractable skylights
that creates an outdoor courtyard on the roof and gave
the citizen a new vantage point to see their
community.
And then these are two libraries that I'm
going to speak about, just quickly show you
and end with, in Washington that I worked
with Ginnie Cooper on. And they are two libraries
in two communities in southeast and southwest
of DC. in Anacostia and a close neighbor. And
in a way, they were communities, one not so
depressed, but another that was a low-income
community. And it was about trying to imagine
this infrastructure that would create a sense
of social pride in the socializing of knowledge sharing
and create a building that would deliver
new services to these communities, which would
help to empower the generations in the community
in their aspirations and in their life, in
a sense.
So it's really, how does a building that is
a new piece of infrastructure, that's not
just a kind of utilitarian box, but something
which sets up something very specific, engage
with these very diverse, suburban-like communities?
And to create a kind of connection to this
bigger idea of what the library can offer.
So this is just an image of the team and some
of the libraries that were all done, where
two of us are in there. These are just giving
you the images of the communities. This is
Francis Gregory, which is next to a park.
Some of the reference images, this idea of
a kind of new public space.
This building was set up almost as the idea
of the public room that connects to the landscape.
Its upper levels had sort of meeting and community
rooms. The children's library was brought
upstairs.
And so you have this volume within this volume.
The skin of the building is modulated so that
it expands and contracts, depending on your
orientation. The elevation looks like diamonds
that are all the same size, but they were
all contracting and expanding to do this notion
of this growth form. And the building is actually
40% insulated. It's a highly sustainable building.
But it presents the perception of what glass
is as a kind of dichotomy. As you sort of
turn around the corner, you see it in a different
light. And as you come to it, you see it in
a different way. So it has a porous sort of
surface around it to do with storm water management,
et cetera. And as you kind of move around
it, what you think is thin becomes thick.
And as you move into it, you see that you're
in this wooded pavilion of these sort of dilating
diamonds that are bathed in light.
And creates this room that becomes a series
of lenses to the forest and to the community.
And it becomes a room where teaching, learning,
and activities are happening. And the stacks
are also in the space. They're in kind of
enclosed chambers of different forms using
thick glass and thin glass, et cetera. Moments
where the form releases, they become very
vertical, vertigious, it sort of dissolves.
And then children's library and community
spaces. The building in its context. Disappearing
in the winter and the summer.
And then the second, in a different community,
was Bellevue, which has a kind of topography
that's fascinating, because it's a sort of
series of hills with a very typical house-builder
architecture. Detached homes, but very fascinating
sort of devices of these stilts that negotiate these landscapes. And I became very
fascinated by that.
And so this is the institution here. It's
round about these houses. We sought to make
a form which had a kind of an agglomerating
character. A series of smaller forms, and
then a larger body. Smaller forms would start
to create these very special rooms which would
frame the city, the community, in different
ways, giving you vantage points to it, but
also would create elevations to explore. And
to have a place that would be a way for the
community to re-think their own environment,
but also see it as a kind of center where
they can come together. On the ground plane,
volumes were elevated to create a plaza where events could happen. Students
would meet under-- this is south-facing--
so it would be under these volumes, creating
a sort of informal teaching, arrival, gathering
space, community space for the community.
The library you would come into would offer
digital and popular services on the ground
floor, and then you would rise up the building.
So here into different spaces
and stacks. Children's library on this floor.
And that's going to rise again up to a space
where you would have other stacks and sort
of arrival on the final floor, where
you'll be able to enter these chambers. So
this children's library has a small sleeping
parlor for children, which looks over its
children. Sort of a sleeping, storytelling
pod that would be specific to this building
or section.
So it's really a kind of spiral to this view.
Here's the building in its context. The arrival.
Great, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Great.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
What I'm going to contribute to this discussion,
I hope, will nicely dovetail with the presentation
David has made here. And I'm giving you what
is basically a kind of 10-minute recipe version
of what could be an hour-long discussion about
what is the mix of elements, programmatic,
mission-based, the fine-grained and macro
considerations that, in my view, ought to
be points of reference in a conversation about
the future of libraries. And like every recipe,
this is one where an expert chef knows the
importance of ingredients, but also the freedom
that exists to combine and re-combine in ways
that make sense. And that making sense process
for me is all about something that I think
is exquisitely present in David Adjaye's work,
which is an intense sensitivity to what it
is that place and space do in a given place.
The way in which they can serve as catalysts.
The way in which they resonate with the history,
with the context, with the entire environment
within which a library performs its function.
So what I'm going to do here in this kind
of short 10-minute version is just walk through
a couple of elements that seem to be interesting
pieces of the larger puzzle of answering the
question of what a library could be or should
be in the 21st century. So I'm going to start
with some things that I don't think it should
be or could be plausibly in the 21st century.
If you ask people at the turn of the 19th
century, entering the 19th century, and then
at the beginning of the 20th century, what
a library is-- and indeed, this is an image
that continues to haunt our imagination when
we think of answering the question of what
is a library-- the answer was an Industrial-era
storage system for books.
And much of the history of late 19th century
libraries and many of the legacy libraries
of today allocate an enormous percentage of
their interior space to this storage function.
Indeed, that storage function was viewed as
a kind of sublime advance in the history of
the library as an institution. People stood
outside of New York Public as the steel stacks
were being built, and looked at them with
the same admiration that they looked at the
building of skyscrapers in the same era. And
I do not think we are in that era anymore.
So one of the exciting questions we must confront
as a community of people who are thinking
creatively and actively about the nature of
knowledge spaces is, what are all the great,
cool things we can do with a lot of that space
that was dedicated before to mere storage?
The second ingredient that I don't think we
need to think about is what I think of as
the consummate dumb space of the contemporary
world, which are computer workspaces. They
look little more like-- they barely differentiate
themselves from tobacco-- you know, places
where people were rolling cigars. I think
we can do more creative, interesting things
with a world where the database has become
one of the defining features of the world
of knowledge sharing, exchange, production,
and so forth. And one of the things, of course,
that the database does, and its ubiquity does--
the fact that it can be accessed through devices
that may fit in my pocket, or that ride in
my briefcase-- is to raise, I think, really
powerful and rich and important questions
about where the library begins and ends. And
what it is that a place in space can do that
the database cannot.
Databases are not places. And the knowledge
that they convey means something or is of
trivial importance in relation to the places
where that knowledge is activated. And I think
the question about what a library could or
should be today is a question about how databases
intersect with local places and realities
and stories.
So with these two excluded ingredients, I
want to turn to a set of possible ingredients
that we could think of. And I already anticipated
my number one point, which is thinking creatively
about storage. And that can mean a number
of different things. Of course, it isn't an
invitation to abandon the storage function
of libraries. I think that storage function
remains vital.
But we can be selective. We can adopt a qualitative
approach to the idea of, what are the assets
whose physicality is a tremendous core feature
of the experience of a knowledge space like
the library? And what kind of things do we
want those collections to do in relation to
the communities that animate and activate
a space? And of course, the answer is going
to be very different in a research library
and in a local branch public library, because
of the nature of the kind of activation processes
we're talking about.
Number two-- documents, of course, are migrating
into digital environments and formats, but
we are printing and producing more print artifacts
than ever in the history of printing today.
And so we have this whole world of hybrid
media, which has, by the way, always been
the world of the library, but in a new form,
in a new configuration. So how do we create
spaces that allow us to work across those
kinds of platforms in the way that people
actually read, think, exchange, share today?
That's a core question. Within that question
is a question of where we add value to, through
the design of the physical spaces that are
under discussion.
The second question I want to talk about is
special collections, I think, as part of the
answer to the question of what do we do with
all that cool open space that we're no longer
going to lock down in the form of storage,
of shelving systems, and so forth. One thing
we can think about are what are those collections
and sets of objects that truly speak of the
place where they are located, that tell stories
about the nature of institution, about collecting
practices, about the communities that inhabit
a given location. And so I think the privilege,
the role of special collections, collections
that typically cut across categories, also
from the world of objects, to the world of
documents and books, to every kind of conceivable
imagined form of documentation of a process
or a practice-- those kinds of categories
and collections seem to me to offer special
opportunities. They tend to be buried. They
tend to be hard to get at. If we can bring
them out into spaces where they're open to
interaction, I think we're beginning to explore
this world of possibility that, moving away
from a storage-based understanding of a library,
we're able to do.
The next question I want to turn to is to
connections. That kind of storage answer to
the question of the library, of course, tended
to emphasize collections as the centerpiece,
of the mission, of the identity of libraries.
And of course, collections are fundamental
to what libraries are, who they are, who they
serve, their histories, and so forth. But
the collections were always the basis for
connections. And I think orienting our gaze
towards the question of who we serve, how
we serve them, how we construct that spatial
platform as a platform that makes connections,
that served as a catalyst for connections,
is an essential part of this re-thinking process.
I've already anticipated, in a sense, with
respect to special collections-- I think I
see one of the opportunities that we have
in this re-thinking and re-design process,
to really think about some of those kinds
of forms of selection and partitioning and
specialization that gave rise to separate
institutions-- museum, the archive, the library.
Different kinds of museums, archives, and
libraries. There are good reasons for those
separations, but there are also effects that
those separations have that are in tension
with processes of discovery and knowledge
sharing.
And I think that one of the opportunities
we have-- again, thinking about this, all
this space that we can now re-curate and re-design--
is thinking about how we create conversations
across media types, across different categories
of objects. How we treat them, curate them,
tell stories with them. Interpret them in
dialogue with one another, rather than separating
paper documents from three-dimensional objects
from artworks, and so on down the line. I
think the opportunity to think about what
a library is in terms of the categories of
objects that are on the shelves, the proliferation
of maker spaces in libraries today, which
is a gesture in this direction, suggests that
maybe tools, tools that allow us to learn,
to tell stories, to make arguments, ought
to be on the shelves alongside books. That
the kind of bookishness of the storage based
model needs to be expanded to encompass other
kinds of forms of learning and knowledge that
involve the hand and not just the mind.
This was a concept that was come up with in
a design studio that I was involved in-- the
GSD and my team at metaLAB-- [INAUDIBLE] a
couple of years. The notion of cool spots.
I'm sure all of you can remember the moment
when you used to walk around with your mobile
devices looking for hot spots, because hot
spot was like an oasis in the desert. You
were out seeking, you know, those three bars,
where you knew that actually had access to
the world.
Well, we now live in a world of ubiquitous
hot spots. The world has become a hot spot.
And the library has this special role as serving
as a platform of connection, but also of disconnection.
How do we want to design forms of disconnection?
It's a different way of framing the question
of the kind of ways in which libraries have
always served as places of refuge, as places
of contemplative remove from the everyday,
and yet, of engagement, re-engagement, from
that perspective, of contemplative engagement.
So I think the question of how we design hot
spots, the levels of disconnection that we
want buildings, in a sense, to create, enforce,
to open up, I think, is a really rich possibility,
not to be underestimated.
I've already anticipated this question of
moving between the hand and the mind, thinking
about the notion of tools as part of the set
of learning assets that libraries make available,
so I'm not going to dwell on that. I think
that the notion of librarians themselves,
but also the communities that animate libraries,
as being engaged, in somehow a kind of expanded
sense of curatorial practices, where we use
the objects, whether they're documents, or
they are collections of objects, to tell stories,
to share, to expose processes of learning
as they're happening, to solve community problems--
I think those are all opportunity spaces to
really think about curatorial practice, the
curation of knowledge and culture as one of
the activities that we want to physically
facilitate through the design of spaces.
And I think, particularly, the re-design,
the re-use, the [FRENCH] of stack structures
to use as exhibition spaces strikes me as
an interesting hypothesis. I like that idea.
And that's we like to call in our group programmable
stacks. Imagine that stacks-- because we have
information systems, we have databases, we
no longer need to worry about books being
in an universal order. What if we can constantly
re-shuffle them, like a deck of cards, to
tell different kinds of stories? This is something
that is available to us as an option.
Last but not least, I want to emphasize the
importance of process, of libraries as places
where we see learning taking place in a social
setting. One of the things that the space
and the place do is really to create these
forms of visibility about processes that otherwise
pass unnoticed. I think this is particularly
important in environments like universities,
where there's so many amazing things always
happening, but it is so difficult to actually
be aware of them, to see them, to experience
them. I think the library has an opportunity
to be that place.
And so, just to conclude, I want to come back
to this notion of the library as an institution,
whose fundamental objective is really to perform,
to be a hybrid. Not to be a single thing,
not to be the place where knowledge or information
is stored, but rather a place that's a hub,
that's a platform, a lab, a showcase, a switchboard,
somewhere you make connections. But above
all, a place that somehow has deep roots and
intersects deeply with all of the dynamics
that would grant meaning and activate the
potential for a physical structure to serve
as a catalyst within a community of learning.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you. If I can appropriate your introduction,
I'll go right into mine, because there's so
many themes that you bring up that are quite
resonant with the three case studies that
I'll try to elaborate on.
I was part of an MIT focus group on the future
of spaces of learning and the question of,
what is the function of the campus going to
become once there are all these online courses?
Why, if you can educate 50,000 people, would
10,000 people come here? And of course, we've
lived through that theme over hundreds of
years, with the notion of the book killing
architecture, or the building. And yet we
know that certain things persist over time,
and there are good reasons for that.
We live in a time where the space of learning,
or the space of reading, or the library, is
at once on our couch at home, it's by the
sea, it's on the train home. So we understand
the ubiquity of our ability to tap into the
world. At the same time, the way that we blend
low culture, high culture, personal space,
and public space has formed us in quite different
ways. We no longer have to wait for Thursday
to watch that series. We can download them
at will.
And so one of the big questions that MIT asked
us was, why is the curriculum bundled in such
a way, when you can just take somebody else's
bike, or somebody else's car? So the whole
notion of de-bundling as a conceptual idea
became a central theme to begin to think of,
how many other ways are there to learn? You
learn by interning, you learn by researching,
you learn by extending your education to seven
years or compressing it to three years. Nobody
said that four years is the right amount.
We also know that place matters. There is
something about the aura, the sense of a place,
that is not replaceable, and that's what makes
UVA different than MIT. And somehow,
we come to learn those things. At an organizational
level, we looked quickly at all sorts of teaching
spaces, learning spaces, top-down sort of
learning, and the ideological implications
that come with that.
The whole notion of the hardness and the idea
that you're learning on a flat playing field.
The hierarchies are broken down. Spaces of
the TEAL that we have right here, where
you're at once connected to the world, but
connected to each other in a space of collaboration.
Our own Gershenfeld, and the idea that learning
is done in a laboratory with many different
devices concurrent with each other. Or, you
know, the space of debate, as it were.
And yet, somehow, the space of architecture
is not yet defined. And we know the presence,
the aura, that that has. Think, if you will,
about our own library here. Some years ago,
it was this dark and somehow dingy space.
But with the opening of the oculus, that is
the one thing that opened up this pantheon,
which has become yet a place again. So the
importance of architecture-- and I'm being
opportunistic here, of course-- is that it
is central, in fact, to the cultivation of
a campus, and in this case, the cultivation
of a library.
The two case studies I'll present to you very
quickly are the University of Melbourne, the
Melbourne School of Design, and I'll end with
the RISD Library. In the context of the Melbourne
Uni, the building of a new school of architecture
and design planning became the opportunity
to break down the traditional boundaries between
what we call, or what we think of, design
and the other disciplines on campus. Engineering,
over there, anthropology, over there. And
so the notion of the ground plane being opened
up and extending the public into the building,
essentially, giving over the entire base to
the entire campus, was something that was
vital to making this the new center of the
university. At the same time, the idea of
creating a new street that ran through there
enabled the possibility to create a triad
between the library, or the traditional library,
broken down, dissolved, the FabLab, which
is just right above there, the space of making,
and the exhibition space.
Here, Tom Kvan, the dean of the school,
had this idea that places of research, places
of thinking, need to find a way to externalize
that through the act of making. And making
is a form of knowledge. You're producing a
form of knowledge. But what if you produce
a form of knowledge and have no way to communicate
it to a broader public? And the exhibit space
becomes that opportunity.
So the building becomes a spatialization of
this idea of the street that breaks down the
barriers between these spaces. These spaces,
in turn, connect to the campus symbolically
and literally. And the actions that belong
traditionally in this or that space leak out
into shared spaces, informal spaces. So if
spaces of the library making end up being
divided not by function, but by things like
noise, or smell, or privacy, or scale.
Other kinds of programmatic functions take
over. So the library effectively leaks up
into the building to the space, in fact, above
the exhibition hall.
Now, the section of this building is quite
important. Because by building a new piano nobile
for the building, we solved, in a way, two
problems. A school of design dedicated to
about 2,000 designers without any dedicated
space for design.
So what did that mean? It was a kind of trick
to dovetail the spaces of scholarship with
the spaces of design and what are called hot
spaces. Not hot as in wired, but hot as in
schedulable spaces, hot desks. What happens
in the morning, what happens in the afternoon,
what happens in the evening.
So effectively, the library moves up the building,
and the design moves down the building, effectively
embracing each other. And the entire space,
what would become the traditional reading
room of a library, has now lifted up, gaining
natural light, and then the taxonomy of the
building is impacted by it. What would have
been the traditional corridor is leaking systematically
on every floor into different spaces of design,
of research. And then different pieces of
furniture begin to get associated with the
kinds of collaborations that you would do,
not only in design, but also in the library.
Collective works, individual works, drafting,
crit spaces, social spaces-- all of these
come together in a kind of sectional hybrid
that identifies the importance of the intricate
configuration of the space with the larger,
symbolic, and figural ambitions of identifying
the totemic importance of some of these spaces
that need to be rightfully enclosed for acoustic reasons.
And so we are not shy of what architecture
can do in this context, and are, you know,
rightfully aware of the history that comes
with-- with these kinds of gestures.
Now, some years before this, a graduate, myself,
of the Rhode Island School of Design, we were
asked to look at the hospital trust building,
the Fleet Bank at that time, and the entire
building was being looked at for the new dormitories.
What they didn't know was what was going to
happen with the banking hall.
Carol Terry, who had been already theorizing
the future of the library some 30 years ago,
had a very clear sense of what this to become.
And it's really under her tutelage that we
entered into this discussion in any sense.
And so the idea that this vast and heavy monolith
of dormitories would be riding over the library
would mean effectively that this is their
living room. This is their lounge. This is
their social space.
Also something quite ironic was this idea
that Carol brought to us. In the previous
library, ironically, the students had no access
to books. What did she want to do? She wanted
to make a browsing library, to make books
accessible once again. Knowing fully well
that they see everything on their screens,
their iPhones, and laptops, she wanted a space
where the word and the image come together.
And that has something to do with the library
of a school of art, the visual arts. Knowing
that knowledge is internalized in very different
ways, we look at the picture first, then we
read the words, and that's how knowledge begins
to happen. That's how you light the fire.
Now, in the banking hall, it turns out that
what she had in mind was, you know, about
double the amount of programs, so it could
not have been fulfilled in that, in the existing
square footage. So building new structures
was a kind of indispensable aspect of being
able to pull this project off. And because
of purely technical reasons, code, reasons,
we needed not only to make the mezzanine accessible
with a new elevator, but also those spaces
that would need to-- otherwise not be able
to fit. The spaces of video watching, spaces
of studying that would go on top of that,
making them accessible meant that we needed
bridges, and stairs, and things that would
ultimately transform this library into something
else beyond the living room.
The staircase that connects them, the main
plaza, the central space that brings the campus
together, is also its main theater. That theater
is the living room of the campus, in one sense,
but then there are many other types of reading
areas, research areas, spaces of intercollaboration
and interaction around it. But just to imagine
what happens in this space in the abstract,
over time we came to understand that theater,
which was never something significant at RISD,
began to have a life of its own on campus.
Weddings. Music. And of course, arts. The
space of drawing. That this becomes a theater
for drawing is an essential part and extension
of the-- of the-- nature lab of the Rhode
Island School of Design. So important to its
foundation program. So the library is everything
but the space of the book, and at the same
time, Carol was able to get over 80% of the
books, all as the insular wrap around this
main public space. I'll end, then, with this
idea of flexibility. On the one hand, the
notion of spaces today under huge economic
duress, need to be absolutely flexible. And
you-- you must imagine that they will certainly
become something else in 10 years, in 30 years.
So the idea of the-- the programmable floor,
or the programmable ceiling, but free of any
definitive program, is important. But also,
the notion that some notions about flexibility
have to do with something that is irreducible--
the scale of the individual, the scale of
five people working together, the dark space,
the light space, the acoustic space, and one
has to be mindful of those.
But above all, the idea that the audience
that you're serving is a public. And is a
public that extends the field of the urban
realm into these buildings, and makes them
culturally vital. And that was one of the
missions that Carol sought to bring into this
building, and she did. This is not the RISD
library. In fact, it invites the entire city
of Providence, and beyond, to come inside.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello. I'm very pleased to be with you here
this evening. You will not see pretty pictures
from me. You've seen pictures of libraries
that I had something to do with already. I'm
the representative of the public library.
And I'm going to talk to you a bit about public
libraries. You'll hear many of the same comments
and words that you've heard from the three
previous speakers as well. And I promise to
close with one of my favorite library stories
at the moment when I learn that my time is
nearly up. So you can have that to look forward
to. Anna gave us a few questions to respond
to, and I'm going to do that here as well.
First, for those of you who don't know about
public libraries, they really are the magic
places in the world. They were for me when
I was a child. My guess is many of you would
have similar stories to tell. Public libraries
are funded locally. More than 90%, in some
cases, as much as 98% of the money, is approved
by those local people elected to make the
hard decisions about where tax money goes
on a very local basis. So they're very different
from one another, and each very responsive
to its own community. At the same time, public
libraries are more alike one another than
they are different from one another, and that's
part of the way that the-- that the magic
happens.
And yes, as you've heard others say, we are
not about storage any more. We are, in fact,
about how to make the space that the community
needs at that particular time and in that
particular place. And our colleagues and partners
in doing so are often architects. One of the
questions was, what is the role of architecture
in determining the future of the library?
You know, you saw some of those wonderful
images from the previous speakers of what
public libraries are. One of the things that
happens with a new building or a newly designed
space is everybody pays attention in a different
way than they did before. You walk in expecting
it to be different than it was before because
it looks different. And it gives you that
as a way of doing it. If architecture did
nothing else, other than give people the opportunity
to change the way they look at something and
think of it, it would serve a wonderful purpose
for all of us.
And public libraries, that is ever true. In
public libraries in local communities, there
are people who have the stories that I said
was mine, that the library was the magic place
I found out about the world, and many, many
other stories. And often, there are people
who want those libraries to stay exactly as
they have been. That library of their imagination,
of their past as they remember it now. So
architecture helps to say, there is something
a little different going on here, in that
exact way.
One of the challenges of public libraries
is because we do belong to the public, that
means everybody has a say in what it's going
to be, and has an opportunity to critique
what you're going to do with the building
that's coming and with the services that are
there. It's kind of David Adjaye not to tell
the story of the woman in one of the communities
that he showed the library of, who stood up
at a public meeting and said she had been
trying to call England and talk to Prince
Charles, because she heard he didn't like
David's buildings, and she didn't like it
either. And she wanted to see how that could
happen together. True story, yes, David? Right.
She's become a fan of the building, finally,
but really wanted it to be in red brick, and
just like her house, and just like her neighborhood.
And was quite sure that what we were talking
about wasn't going to fit, and wasn't going
to work for her in her neighborhood.
But in fact, the role that libraries play
in local communities is really magic. For
many people who are disconnected with the
government that is in fact theirs, it is the
way that that government says, this is what
you are worth. This beautiful building, with
all of these magic things inside, to open
up the world to you, and the place is for
you to be, this is yours. And it's your government
that has created and provided that for you.
It really is a wonderful thing to be involved
in.
So in fact, architects and librarians are
allies as we move forward together in this
brave new world of what libraries become.
And they are changing. They used to be about
collections, as you've heard from others.
We are now, still, about connections in a
way that makes sense, and helps people find
a way to connect with everybody in their community
in one way or another, and with that community
and that local government, very often. That
civic engagement is an important role for
libraries, and it's something that in public
libraries, we pay a great deal of attention
to.
It also becomes increasingly a place for collaboration.
You saw that with the RISD library, and the
ways-- and the Melbourne project, and the
way that different disciplines worked together
and were a part of what it is that was being
done in that building. And collaborations,
or collaborating, is a big part of what libraries
do.
And we are moving increasingly into being
places for creation. Now, it is usual for
people to come to the library to create a
report for a group of sixth graders that are
going to go to the library study rooms to
work together, or a dance project that somebody
wants to create. And the library's a great
place to meet a musician you don't know, and
try to figure out how to make that happen.
Or to learn how to read. Nothing says, I don't
really need literacy training than walking
into a public library, and that's a common
place for that to happen, too.
So now, I'm told it's nearly the end of my
time, and I get to tell you what is one of
my favorite library stories. And I think it
talks about what the library can do and does
do. A number of years ago, in a library where
I used to work, a very, very talented children's
librarian came to me with an idea. She was
trying to figure out how we could help our
community teach children to read, when so
many start kindergarten behind, and stay behind
as they move forward. Her great idea became
a program that I've used at very nearly every
library where I have worked.
And in this program, books, usually paperback
books, usually ones that are not worth a great
deal of money and that we got quite inexpensively,
would go to the library, to the classroom.
And a volunteer would go to that classroom
every three weeks. We targeted classrooms
where the reading level was not at grade level,
and where these kids needed to learn the magic
of reading, and certainly didn't have that
sense about this very hard-to-do thing. So
the volunteers-- sometimes staff, sometimes
volunteers-- would go and they would book
talk. In the library world, think of it as
the previews of coming attractions in movies.
It's where you tell enough about the book
so that this eight-year-old or nine-year-old
or ten-year-old wants to get their hands on
that book. And because-- and when they're
done with the book, they can pass it on to
somebody else, bring it back, whatever. We
don't care. It's to get them to have that
book in their hand, and excited about opening
that book, that is the real point of what
you're doing.
So one of the people that worked on this program
told this story. She told about being in a
classroom. It was a fourth-grade classroom.
And in that classroom, there were four languages
spoken in addition to English, so she had
three language interpreters who were interpreting
her words for the fourth-graders in that class
that were transitioning to English. And at
the end of her program, as often happens when
you do that kind of presentation, all the
kids rushed up and wanted to tell her things.
You know, I love that book about the dog!
You know, I love dogs! My cousin has a dog!
You know, all of that kind of chatter.
And during all of this time, there was a little
boy who was standing right beside her. He
didn't say anything. And after all the kids
had had their say, Kathy leaned over and she
said, did you have something you wanted to
say? And he put his hand in his pocket, and
he reached out his hand, and in it was his
library card. And he said, I American now.
Now he wasn't, of course, but he was, in all
the ways that are wonderful. And whatever
the library has in the future, I know that
that will continue to be an ingredient of
it. Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm not sure how I'm supposed to follow
that story, but I'm going to try. And when
I first thought about what I wanted to say
tonight, I wanted to talk about what a remarkable
time it is to be a librarian. And it really
is. I mean, we can take nothing for granted
right now in libraries. And it's-- that's
kind of remarkable. The challenge in trying
to understand what a library as a space would
look like, should look like, should do when,
as Jeffrey says, we can carry much of human
knowledge in our pocket, that's a really cool
challenge. And so, you know, I feel a great
privilege to be in this profession right now.
That's really cool.
But at 10:30 this morning, I had an experience.
I had this experience a lot in the year I've
been here, but I had this experience where
it's felt like a really remarkable time to
be at MIT. So for those of you who didn't
hear the news at 10:30 this morning, MIT announced
that a group of scientists at MIT, along with
the collaborators from Caltech, detected,
for the first time, gravitational waves. Which
I don't really understand what they are, but
I understand-- but what I know is that they
are ripples in the time-space continuum that
were predicted by Einstein in 1916. And at
the time, he predicted that we'd never be
able to really see them or detect them. And
after years and years, and many, many collaborators,
we detected them.
And in the article about that, one of the
scientists on the team talked about it being
a very visceral experience, that they could
actually hear this moment when two black holes
merged together and collided to create another
black hole. And so there's something there,
right, about a sensory experience. That in
this thing that is a kind of science, that
is for those who are not scientists sort of
beyond our comprehension, that is still very
visceral and sensory. And I think there's
some things there to be played with around
library as space, and around the question
that Jeffrey raises about, sort of, what we
do with this space that we can free up with
collections? And I think the question before
that is, well, which collections should we
keep, and why? And maybe they're the ones
where they help us have these sensory experiences.
There's a couple of other library pieces to
this gravitational waves story which I'm still
fascinated by. One of things that was really
wonderful about it is-- I think we all at
MIT, or everyone I ran into today at MIT,
felt like they were a part of it. Right? We
were all-- I walked a little taller today.
I mean-- I had nothing to do with this, I
had never even heard-- but I feel pretty darn
good to be at MIT today. It's that connection.
I feel connected to research that happened
here. Because I'm here, because I'm part of
this community. And I think, again, libraries
can facilitate that, can enhance that.
Another interesting library part of that story
is that within about 20 minutes of the announcement
that came out, the website that hosts the
article that describes the research behind
this was having some connection problems.
Right? But-- people wanted to read the research.
And they were-- you know, thousands of people
were hitting that website, the Physical Review
Letters of the American Physics Society, and
there were some connection problems.
OK-- what's really cool about that is librarians
at MIT were scrambling to try and figure out
how to make sure that folks here could still
have access to that research. And literally
as I'm speaking, some of the rockstar librarians
that work here, and the staff and the people
who work here at the MIT libraries, are curating
a collection of articles that are the foundational
research that led up to this huge breakthrough
in science. They're curating a collection
of articles that are available in D space,
which is our open-access repository. So these
will be articles that are open to the world
to read. This is our way of saying, we do
this stuff at MIT, and we're sharing it. Who
is our community? Our community is anyone
who wants to understand this amazing breakthrough
that happened here at MIT today. Right? We
have a big community. And we're connected,
and we want to be that place, whether it's
in-- digitally or physically, we want to be
that place of connection to each other, and
to science, and to learning, and to possibility.
You know, last night, David talked about magic
here. So we've talked about connection, and
we've talked about magic. And last night,
David said something about how his-- and I
hope I get this right-- so that he sees part
of his job as to sort of cast a spell with
the work that he does to make people think
something is important. And I want to extend
that. It just was such a lovely way of talking
about how space can do that, how places and
physicality can do that, can communicate that.
For me, what I want-- I want libraries to
do that, want spaces to do that. I also want
them to be-- to communicate and to be places
where people know that they are important,
and that they belong here. I want the libraries
to be that space where the students and the
community can feel that that-- those riches,
and that the science that happens here, the
learning that happens here, the riches-- that
they are a part of that, the way that I felt
a part of the announcement this morning. I
want the libraries to be that space where
you can-- it communicates to the community
all of the science that's happening today,
all that has happened previously, here and
elsewhere, that they have access to it, that
they're a part of it. Similar to the experience
that the young child described, I'm American
now-- in a research library, I'm a scholar
now. I'm a scholar now. And I get to be in
this place.
And we used to feel that, I think. You know,
I-- I told a story last night, and I'll tell
it again today. I'm a first-generation college
student, so when I walked into the library
at Duke University, to Perkins Library, too
many years ago, for the first time-- to see
those books, to see those stacks of books,
and to feel like, I get to read these. These
are for me too, now. That's an amazing experience.
And is it just books that can do that? I think
not. I think it could be really interesting,
and is really interesting to think about libraries
as spaces-- digital, physical spaces, cultural
spaces, metaphorical spaces, where people
feel that they belong in the scholarly conversation.
And that's, you know, what I hope we'll be
able to do here at MIT, what I know we'll
be able to do here at MIT. So, thanks very much. [APPLAUSE]
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
I think we covered magic. I was going to open with magic. But I really do
feel like there's enough ways that we've entered
the topic already. And maybe the way in which
architecture serves it will come back. I will
ensure that to some extent. So maybe
let's go to the next big topic, the future.
I mean, obviously you've also all addressed
that to some extent. So maybe we're going
to be repeating some of the things, but maybe
slightly differently formulated or in conversation now.
And it's a key topic tonight. It's on our
poster. And David Adjaye will participate
in every event. If you will participate this
semester with us, future will be on the table.
In a way, MIT has copyrighted the word. But
it's also always on architects minds. And
it's, in a way, part of the job description
of the design process. So even when one thinks
about historical continuum as an architect,
they are really kind of thinking in the prospective
mode.
But if we can begin to sort of pry it open
and slice it, I actually want to go to something
that Jeffrey didn't say today,
but has said in his work on the library after
the book, in a way, and I'll paraphrase. He
said something that if in the past the library's
main task was to respond to society's scarcity
of information, it's contemporary mandate
is to deal with its opposite-- the abundance
of information.
And then from the other angle, David Adjaye
has said that, in a way, I'm not taking about
the library specifically, that we need a new
interpretation of civicness. And that on top
of architectural terms, on top of maybe needing
to edify, we need that civicness to also be
production of a hybrid space with multiple
signals, multiple entries, multiple cultural
references, and that heterogeneity of meaning.
And so it seems like future is more and more
hybrid. And so I am offering to that to you
collectively to enter from various angles.
Well, maybe one starting point, just to embroider
a little bit further on this question of managing
the overabundance of information, which, by
the way, as my colleague Ann Blair has
shown in some of her work, was a problem that
was acutely felt very early in the history
of printing. I mean, in the 16th century people
were in an absolute panic about the overabundance
of print matter. Imagine how they would have
felt today.
[LAUGHTER]
They didn't even have even an nth percentage
of even the redundancy of information channels that we have today.
But I think at every moment of that challenge,
one of the things that keeps shifting and
that's really rich, think we'll come back
to your question about the future, what's
emerging as a new set of challenges. There's
a different kind of cognitive sort of style
that characterizes these shifts in media and
information and ways of interacting and so
forth.
I think designing spaces for-- we're still
at the beginning of the digital revolution.
It's hard to remember that. We have this sense
of being kind of overwhelmed by all the transformations.
But those transformations have barely gelled
in new knowledge forms, and new cultural forms,
and new social forms.
So I think it is an incredibly challenging
task. But what we do see is a new kind of
hybridity where things are being realigned.
And the privilege that certain forms once
enjoyed-- like the print record-- those privileges
no longer exist in that same stable relationship
to other forms, other channels and so forth.
And for me, because I love to beat up on computer
work rooms because they seem to be
the-- not only really dumb things but they
really crystallized the central problem which is weaving together information in space in ways that add value
rather than simply being functional sort of
post-factum legacy solutions.
We talk a lot about smart spaces. If there
was ever an institution that's associated
with the notion of smart spaces, it's the
library. But we really don't have good answers
when it comes to the way electronic media
intersect with these other cognitive apps
which are essential to our experience-- the
way we share knowledge, the way we perform
knowledge. And I think it's really an exciting
frontier to be at. Even if it's a challenging one.
Do you want to take on the civic, or you know maybe the
way in which you summon public, or represent it in the building. Either or, I think one is more active than the other.
No, I think this all, the technology
offers to that sort of idea that we understand of it, as this kind of repository of shelving systems, storage, that's kind of open storage that's on display that we so enjoyed and romance
about. And that removal from architecture of that primary idea of the stack in the reading where it
became the kind of two sort of tropes.
I'm going to defend it in a second, but, yeah.
I love it.
And I can go there with two archetypes. In
the system with a certain sort of redundancy
and that as the kind of primary agency in
it's-- I think in a research library, it's
a very different thing. When I'm talking about
a public library in a community, it becomes
something else.
Because in a way the hybridity has a civic
quality that we're discussing here in a library
becomes about a way in which our society is
modernizing and identifying and the way in
which the library becomes a kind of device
that becomes a kind of respite or a glomerating
set of activities that start to make sense
to the sort of the modernity that's happening
around us. Shall I say that?
So in a way, the public library has sot of
become a kind of space that is starting to
kind of take on more of these-- not just mind-issues,
but also body-issues, so it's oscillating between
mind and body as a kind of a space
that is serving communities specifically
away from the commercial agent-- the activities of commercial
space.
Now, a research library is a very different
phenomena. You are talking about an academic
environment. So you have this idea of the
stack and the romance of the stack, and the
need to kind of ritualize the reading room,
the place where the great minds is in, it's
powerful. It's your artifact. It's the thing
that you want to kind of enjoy.
And you want to create a kind of simulation
of that continually. But the question then
is, even for me, the moment when you can capture
that idea becomes Disneyfied. And it just
becomes a caricature of itself as a way to
stage the notion of the environment where
the authenticity's no longer real, but it's
a kind of device to send out.
I agree with you, as an image.
Hybridity is a reality.
This in a way for me was the problem
of the library, of its future, as it's bracketed
by these two notions. On one end, the kind
of amassing and hybridization of the media
in which knowledge is produced, and on the
other, the actual hybridity of, and the need
for, different kinds of references and openings
for a kind of public that is no longer a monolithic
public. Seems like kind of an interesting
question. But I think you sort of take this on differently.
For me, it's an exciting time for me. Because
all of these discussions trigger an understanding
of the discipline of architecture. Which can
be less apologetic than it was maybe 10 or
20 years ago. And so--
I think that's shared at this table.
So the idea that you could produce not only
a form of knowledge, but a form of consciousness
through making a subject through the public.
So for me, if you acknowledge that the civic
or the public isn't monolithic, the language that
is being put, materializes in the way you
specialize things, the way that you organize
them.
It's all part of that process not so much
of mirroring society, but potentially projecting
it in a way that it has never been before.
So the idea of speculation becomes associated
with a positive way of imagining a future,
something that we are always having to be
very apologetic about.
We don't have to talk about this.
Do you want to talk about your two futures?
The zoom in and the zoom out?
Last night when we had the discussion with the
library task force, and our challenge was
to talk to them about how to plan for the
future. I said that I had found it helpful
to think about two futures. The first is what
you can probably figure out is gonna happen.
So we can see a little bit ahead and you're
absolutely right, it's not anywhere near the
midpoint of this digital revolution.
We won't be carrying around things that sometime
we can probably see. We certainly won't need
to plug things in. Maybe we won't even need
to charge them, if we're really lucky. So
we can sort of see that world coming. And
so we have to do the immediate planning for
exactly what that is.
And then what's really fun is to separate
from that the really far-out wild future that
you have no idea of, what might happen-- dare
I give the example I gave last night? I was
at a library program where I heard someone
say, you know we'll soon, within a century
or two, be at the place where people don't
read. Where they don't have to understand
what words mean. It'll all be spoken to them.
Or maybe it's given to them in some other
way we can't imagine. You take a pill and
you know it all, or something.
But when you think about the fact that there
once wasn't reading-- until there was printing,
there was no need for reading. And when you
think about my mathematics work with slide
rules, do kids know what slide rules are anymore?
The world does change, and tools change, and
maybe that's an amazing one, too. So what
would a library be then?
So I think what's interesting to me is to
think about libraries in terms of, as you
said, what's the future that we kind of know
is coming? What's the wild crazy future, right?
But also, what's the future we want?
Yes.
Right? What's the future we want for scholarly
communication, right? Do we want, in fact,
a scholarly communication system that gets
around some of the real brokenness of it now
where one of the biggest breakthroughs of
our generation in science is behind a pay-wall,
right?
Do we want a more open system where that knowledge
is truly available, or truly taking advantage
of the technology where that knowledge could
be in anyone's pocket? If we want that, then
what does that imply for what libraries then
do? Because they used to manage scarcity,
not just in physical form, but also now we're
managing scarcity based on this very broken
system of scholarly communication.
OK, I have a question to the architects on
the panel. I have another. I really do want
to talk about stacks because as this goes
I'm just feeling more and more worried about
the books and about the politics of the knowing
them.
You're worried about that?
Yes. It seems like we're embracing it. So
a specific question to the architects-- and
we have here two architects who dealt with
different emphasis and two different aesthetic
camps, perhaps-- hear immensely about the
material and tectonic effects of their work.
So my question is, what happens when this
aspect of your craft, for somebody to call
it a kind of care for detail, assembling your
materials, the effects of those assemblies--
intersect with architecture of our program
for learning. And here, I bring anything broadly--
library, museum, school. How do you sort of
see the pressure of those programs and those
particular architectures on your own sense
of practice and what have you?
[TALKING TOGETHER]
[LAUGHTER]
I don't see any contradiction at all, because
that's the kind of-- this is world that we
negotiate. And it's actually the world that
we actually find stimulation from. Let's just
talk about the stacks. Because that's the
elephant in the room.
This is, for me, a question about, basically,
architecture itself produces knowledge. And
I thought maybe that this is an unfair question,
because I think there's a right answer, right?
I
think there is a pressure on your architectures
in those situations to speak more like that.
But the way that you asked the question suggests
as if we are these architects with visions,
as if we don't do research just like you do
research.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
My question is, what's the--
The part of the narrative, that I heard, is
that those people, like the Carol Terrys,
like the 15 focus groups that we had in
Melbourne, completely changed the way that
we would have organized space, situate relationships
between people, and not all of that is something
you can articulate in a form like this, but
that the architecture is not naturally just
what it is. It is a struggle to establish
that scenography, if I can put it that
way.
The staging of these relationships is very
much problematic. And then it finds other
ways in which it expresses itself through
materials and hierarchies that effectively
register to your eye, or somebody else's eye,
the icon or what seems to matter. But I think
of ourselves as incredibly nerdy when it comes
to starting a project.
One thing you have to do is to unlearn-- to,
in a way, eradicate your biases. Because everything
you thought you knew, you probably knew wrong.
And every client group, or every culture,
or every geography, in a way, proves to you
that you were wrong in what you thought you
knew.
Does anyone want to comment on this? You're
like, OK, done with that one.
No, I want to talk about stacks.
OK. So as a curator myself, I love the idea--
and as someone who often might say designs,
knowledge as you would maybe say-- as part
of my practice, right? I love the idea that
we could have a way of thinking in test kitchens,
in libraries, or some form of experimental
library, wherever we might be going, that
would include objects, et cetera, that would
have curated assemblies of knowledge objects,
right?
And then we could rely on the librarian or
some other kind of expert to produce those.
But as a researcher who relies on books--
and all the other types of media, right? Maybe
you call it nostalgia, but I feel sort of
stressed about the politics of access to books
without being patronized.
There's something about arriving to a book
stack and not only feeling that kind of knowledge
and being in awe about it, but actually being
able to find your way and curate it yourself
as a researcher. So then, if we get rid of
storage-- because now it's just storage, and
not a kind of political gesture-- what do
you do?
So this is where I get into really magical
thinking. I mean, I love the experience of
walking the stacks. And I believe serendipity
is pretty old. When people say, it doesn't
really happen, it's just nostalgia-- I've
seen it happen. It's real. It's not actually
magic.
I think it's really powerful. But there are
limits to the technology of a book, and the
technology of the book stack, right? When
you navigate those stacks, MIT doesn't have
every book on your topic. So that act of physically
browsing the stacks is incomplete.
And some books are checked out. And some of
what you need isn't a book. It's a map. It's
data. It's images.
And so in my wildest imagination, you can
wander the stacks in an augmented reality
kind of way, so that you're having that visceral
experience of feeling and being in space with
physical books, but you also have access in
some way that someone brilliant here at MIT
will invent for us, to the digital objects
that are related to that. And to understanding
what other people here at MIT are doing that's
related to that topic, so that you can then
meet them in physical space somewhere. So,
my wildest imagination of the future-- and
I think it's possible-- is that browsing the
stacks that we take what really works there--
Yeah, I totally agree. A student in my library
test kitchen a couple of years ago developed
a project around an idea that we had been
elaborating, which I continue to think is
a really cool idea-- First of all, books today,
books that sit on our shelves, are not like
the books that were produced fifty years ago.
They are already data objects before they
are books. They are a radically different
kind of object in many ways than the books
they look just like, except they're different.
But what if every time you searched for a
term in a catalogue, the books-- whether it
was an object, or a set of objects-- they
recognized you when you moved around in physical
space? That is a world of experiences that's
not unlike the serendipitous experience,
but that's actually not a technological problem.
It's a design problem. We could have our ID
tags and books that are plugged into networks
that reflect the eccentric, peculiar intellectual
path thought by a single person. And I think
thinking about how we design that experience--
You don't find that oppressive?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
It could be, but I think if any institution
is gonna get it right, I think a library would
be that kind of institution that could really
explore that world where the digital and the
analog intersect one another in ways that
are productive. They are generative.
This is already happening when
we get that unsolicited email by Pinterest
saying, these are the things that you're interested
in.
I don't always welcome those, but I think
that if they're properly filtered and so forth,
we can create those kinds of experiences and
design them to be productive experiences.
So I'm excited about that idea. And I think
that thinking about books-- even bookish objects
circulate in space. And if the traces of those
invisible acts of looking to retrieve knowledge,
of putting knowledge forms together, were
to become more visible, that's an enrichment.
I mean, I'm sure I'm not the only faculty
member who loves to see what graduate students--
the information they're curating at their
carrels when they're writing dissertations.
Because I discover things when I see them.
Of course, a lot of that activity now is disappearing
into screens. And I can't see that anymore.
And that's a loss for the collective understanding
of who we are, what we're doing, what people
are thinking about. So, that kind of making
it visible, I think, is one of the kind of
core challenges.
Making it visible, making lost connections
visible and knowing who's reading what on
my topic, those are very important things
that libraries can do, and connections that
we can do, but to do so in a way that respects
the privacy of the reader, which is what makes--Ginnie, I know you'll back me up--it's one of those like, deeply
held librarian values. You say those sorts of things
about snooping in a graduate student's desk.
I'm, like, no, you can't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
These are open carrels.
Everybody does it.
Well, there, okay then.
I'm very excited about the idea that the fourth
book in the series that I've just read one,
two, and three of will just magically come
to me.
You can say hi.
No, that's how I see your knowing the person
operate.
Do you want me to call time?
Everyone is happy talking to us. So I
mean, some of my questions got spent but
I did have-- just to get in the conversation,
but I wanted to ask you to engage in a kind
of a futurological experiment of this will
kill that, and give us a version-- obviously,
when Victor Hugo wrote the famous words, this
was a death pronouncement to architecture
against the book, basically saying that architecture's
power to articulate, represent, and assimilate
ideas was going to be replaced by the books
which seemed more permanent and faster.
And I'm wondering, if we were to produce a
statement like that for today, what would
be this and that? Or, you don't have to use
the death metaphor. But I think we were already
sort of going towards-- if we were to be birthing
something as opposed to euthanizing, what
would it be?
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, how long to believe that the promises
of technology would allow us to unleash the
democratic promise of education, that technology
could do that. It hasn't been realized yet.
But I want to believe that we can, right?
And some of that has to do with, now we really
can't-- the books are not these sacred things.
Knowledge is not only inscribed in limited
numbers of books that you have to belong to
that community to have access to. Now they
can be in your pocket. Can technology really
work to make that true universal knowledge
accessible to all?
I think it's extremely exciting, because in
a way, I think that the limits of printed
matter, of printing, and of creating a world
where we print for every community, this idea
of stacks of paper, so that they can engage,
I think it reached its zenith. And I think
even before the internet. I just
think it's an unsustainable kind of image.
It's a kind of verified, slightly elitist
image. And in a way--
Technology potentially is similar to that.
Yes, and I think that technology is potentially
also an elitist image. You have, an opportunity
to try now to create the kind of forum that
technology can operate in, right? It doesn't
have a sense of aestheticism. I think we're
in the forefront of the thing. The image which
should make a kind of-- For me, the library
becomes a new public square. It really profoundly
becomes less about an object, a palace of
rarefied information, and becomes a forum
of debate.
It's the place where the engagement is happening,
the commentary's happening. If you look at
what's happening in your school, I mean, this
idea that you can publish, and comment, and
debate, and receive information from somebody
who might have the rarefied document, is magical,
and, I think, more reasonable in terms of
a kind of potential future. More sustainable.
So I kind of see that as moral rightsizing
in the end.
In the future that I want to see, and what
I want to get rid of, is I want the future
where just as when you go into a library,
you go looking for something that's for you,
exactly right, and find it. And I want that
applied to every child in this country and
to every person. Whatever the limits of their
opportunities to learn, we in libraries find
a way to augment that. And that's the future
I'd like to see us work to create.
I want to bring the senses back into this,
because I did that slide with the words and
the image. But also the technology is doing
very incredible things, so that what used
to be compartmentalized in terms of those
who have hearing impairments, or those who
cannot see-- all of that is now coming back
into a knowledge base that could be acoustic,
it could be visual, it could be smell. I'm
thinking of, if you remember, last year or
the year before when Ferran Adriá came here.
He was not talking about cooking. He was talking
about the entire knowledge, the alchemy, of
what constitutes cooking.
And the idea that you would think of a special
institute for that is in a way ridiculous
when he is already making the library that
is everywhere. So how do you expand that database
to engage directly with your senses? That,
to me, is fascinating.
I love all of those responses. I think what
they suggest is, that some of these choices
are not mutually exclusive choices. The media
historian in me trained as a medievalist immediately
kicks in these conversations in answer to
Anna's provocation-- media never go away.
So the real questions always have to do with
mixing and matching hierarchies.
We have such a proliferation of channels from
a sensory standpoint, which we've touched
upon. So the question of what a library is
and what it does is just undergoing this kind
of constant expansion over the course of its
modern history, certainly. And the conventions
for how we organize the experience of accessing
knowledge, I think those are all open for
design in a way that they haven't been for
a couple of centuries.
This sort of legacy system, including the
stacks, was the result of a very constructive
moment in history of ideas about access, about
assembly, and so forth. And I think some of
the libraries that really excite me are libraries
much like the one you just mentioned, of materials
materials, things that take us into a different
kind of imaginary space, at least, of what
it is to experience or share or communicate.
The image that you shared was more like a
cabinet of wonders.
It was.
Exactly. And maybe the Wunderkammer is, we
don't want to give up the modes of access
and reliability that I think you were implying
in your reference to the stack, because that
stands for a certain kind of rigor, certain
forms of organization. But I actually think
that's where technology can really be a creative
tool for having it both ways. You can have
programmable stacks where information is still
accessible. Digital objects can exist in multiple
places at the same time.
I was studying, I was programming it.
[LAUGHTER]
You want to be the programmer.
For yourself, you are.
Should we open it to the audience? There's
a lot of you. We could have questions from
the audience. There are two mics on each side,
and if you could come to them or someone will
bring it to you. But let us know if you have
any questions.
Yes.
Leaving is also okay.
[LAUGHTER]
Hey. Thank you for coming and speaking for
us. My question is, that I'm interested in the library,
the act of the collection as an act of curation,
and that curation as an act of gate-keeping.
So I'm interested how you program in a more
open sense of curation. Because you can have
all the contemporary amenities in the world
in a library and still come out with the same
forms of knowledge, modes of understanding.
So how do you break that model of gate-keeping
and open it up to the community and program
that into an integrative structure of a library?
You want to go first, or do you want me to--
Why don't you go first?
I think we-- you're absolutely about that.
In a way, we've touched on that a couple of
times here talking about that crazy idea of
Jeffrey's that instead of following the book,
you're following the person and what their
knowledge source is. In public libraries we
do it in a pretty real and pragmatic way.
So for example, if you want a book at most
of the libraries where I have been, and we
don't own it, we will get it.
We might borrow it from somebody. We more
likely will buy it if it's available and can
be bought. We also follow, as much as we can,
the patterns of individuals and groups within
our community and think, what are we getting
for them?
And so for example, if I'm at a library that
has a tremendous number of kids under the
age of five, what would happen to the picture
book collection is very different than-- you
probably have a very small picture book collection
here, right?
[LAUGHTER]
So, we're not getting to the individual but
we're getting to individuals in that way that,
I think, does it. The fact that it's the public's
library means in many ways we're-- I hate
to use this buzzword-- we're crowd-sourcing
what people are interested in, in having these
programs, and having this or that part of
the collection, and having what's offered,
and really trying to be responsive in that
way. We don't succeed every time, for sure,
but we're working on it.
Yeah, I think another bit of what I think
you're getting at is, the act of duration,
the act of selecting what's going to be in
what is a limited physical space, is a political
act. It is, absolutely. People talk about
libraries as these great neutral spaces. They're
not neutral. They've never been neutral.
Libraries, as an institution, are, by nature,
very political. The idea that the public gets to have access. We're going to buy a couple of copies of this
book, and anyone that wants it can come in
and have it. That's pretty downright socialist,
really.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Books sit next to each other on the shelves
with ideas over which people have shed blood.
Right there, yes. And so libraries have certainly
played this gatekeeper role in many, many
ways. Do we still do that to some extent?
Some of my colleagues in libraries say, you
know, we're still trying to be gatekeepers
even though the fence is gone. And we can
get to everything. So we're standing by this
gate while everybody's just going around us
and getting everything.
But once they get to those things, some of
those information objects are still locked
away. You still need a pass-code of some kind
to get to them. And so for me, I don't want
to be a gatekeeper. I don't want to be a gatekeeper.
I don't want libraries to be gatekeepers at
all.
I want libraries to be these spaces that invite
everyone in to partake of the knowledge. One
of the ways that some folks in research libraries
are talking about, flipping the collection,
is-- what my research libraries have done
historically, on college campuses, is we've
gone out and we've collected all the books
we think the students and the faculty at our
campus want. We put them in buildings.
And we've let you come in and get stuff that
other people have written, and research that
other people have done, and you can have access
to it. And then you write your stuff and you
publish it somewhere, and those other libraries
get copies of that, right?
And so what we're talking about now is sort
of turning the libraries inside out. So the
libraries aren't just for bringing in research
from outside of MIT so that people at MIT
teach and consume it, but it's actually using
the libraries to push the research of MIT
out to the world, to flip it out, so we're
not a gatekeeper anymore. I don't know what
the metaphor is.
But we're throwing our research out there
to everyone. That's what I hope we will become--
and that technology and buildings, right?
I mean, there's a way to signal that with
architecture that I think could be really
cool.
A point, and then a question that could be
a comment on that the book
as an object is a pretty exquisite thing.
So it'd be sad to lose that, or you don't
think the screen is a very good replacement.
And the part about the stacks-- it's not necessarily
that the stack is a useful object, but the
serendipity of the stack.
Remember, I'm doing research when I'm in the
library and I'm looking at the shelf, I'll
often notice a few shelves down there's a
different version of the topic I'm looking
at that's really important, that I didn't
know about. And so that experience, I think,
is very important and would be sad to lose.
But the more interesting question is this
notion of the library being the public square.
It seems like there's a lot of pressure on
the library to be things that we used to have,
like public squares.
[LAUGHTER]
That opens a really powerful question. Because
actually, a lot of what we used to have is
gone. And we don't have it anymore. All those
things that used to be those forums of engagement
and those places where the connectivity happens
have become privatized or taken away.
And that's the difficulty. That's the pressure
on the library. It's interesting that interior
space is become a kind of metaphor for exterior
space. Because exterior is basically commodified
and sold. That's just real.
I mean, is there any way in architecture to
somehow gesture that there's that lack? I
mean like, providing something that there
should already be.
Well I think that there's politics, which
is a different thing. We don't do that. But
I think in architecture we can respond to
this.
We're interested in the city. I mean, we're
talking about libraries and everything, but
I'm interested fundamentally in the human
being in the city with this mechanism that
we invented 10,000 years ago, and how it supports
our life. And that we had this extraordinary
densification that's changed everything, because
we have mass migration to the city. And so
the nature of how we access information, how
we play the social aspect, has completely
changed. And we're not gonna go backwards
unless we destroy the city and invent something
else.
That's a different project. Now we have to
kind of create these spaces that allow these
opportunities to happen. And the library just
kind of found itself moving from just kind
of being a palace of knowledge and of the
elite, the 1%, to becoming the place where
actually the greatest amount of our community
believe in education as a way to create citizens--
has become the lens by which we kind of throw
people through it into the world. So it's
transformed. It's just transforms into the
nature of the way the city is, and the way
in which densification is.
I love the library as a kind of romantic book
stack, but that's just to do with the last
200 years, or 100 years. I mean, it's getting
bigger than that. It's really a lens for creating
people, creating an elite, like in monasteries,
et cetera. It's now a lens for creating the
greatest amount of educated people that we
can make.
So if that's its DNA, let's not get caught up on--For me, I'm just
like, let's get the-- and what I'm interested--
I mean, OK, we can get het up on things, that's
fine. But I'm more interested in the urgency
of integrating models that create the greatest
amount of having the most fun.
I'm an archivist but also an avid sci-fi reader.
And as you were talking about the research
we did, I was just thinking about these things,
necessarily. And it really struck me, thinking
about the lessons in sci-fi. Going back to
a hundred years ago, Einstein was saying these
things don't exist. And now, gosh, did anybody
know that they really are.
And so just thinking about the lessons of
history, but also the lessons of design of
libraries, design of those spaces in science
fiction over time. And using that, are there
architects, people who design, that are particularly
looking to add-- how do we design something
in a sci-fi book that is placed 300 years
in the future, on a different planet? And
does that come into the conversation on thinking
about current design?
Who's the client for that?
It was an architecture question.
What do you guys think about sci-fi in architecture?
Some people are really engaged in sci-fi architecture.
We're not the ones, but--
We're at MIT, though, the home of sensible cities, that was sci-fi
just a few years ago. So yes, it's very much
alive and well. The question is where it goes
next.
Well I don't know if the movie, Mission Impossible,
counts as sci-fi, but that scene where Tom
Cruise is spinning the information around--
I know that the actual--
That's my vision.
All right, I got a signal that we have to
finish. So thank you very much, our panelists,
and thank you everyone.
[APPLAUSE]